e
[Musique]
ouais
en duo
bon sur l'amérique d'un joueur à qui
sait attendre aux journaux et aux
antilles elle que c'est bon de se
retrouver
n'est ce pas tiens il ya vraiment un
rendez vous que je ne manquerais pour
rien au monde c'est celui que j'ai avec
vous tous les mercredis à partir de
16h45 ça il est signalée en rouge avec
une énorme croix dans mon agenda pour
commencer à hugo on va ça va très très
bien c'est très très bien at war oh oui
je suis en pleine forme bon et puis
alors je suis ravi parce que tu vas
comprendre pourquoi dans quelques
petites secondes c'était mission est
placée sous le signe de l' aventure
j'adore l'aventuré cancer tue moi est ce
que tu es quand même spontanément comme
ça naturellement d'un tempérament aussi
aventureux à mono point du tout ma
mésaventure je les réserve pour le
mercredi les autres jours je reste
tranquille à troll homologue slovène
vraiment ma cheminée et la rivière ni
dans les monts cache nez alors fait
taire quand même intéressant la semaine
oui oui il repose au oui tu reprends des
forces ça ça vaut le goût des bons
attaquants tu fais bien immédiate ou
rigaux tu sais qui je vais présenter non
aux deux candidats à la famille qui va
s'élancer donc sur des parcours en ta
compagnie
je vous demande un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour la famille de la
foire
j'espère que tout va bien se passer sur
pour vous mais vous savez que vous les
téléspectateurs donc l'été les joueurs
bien évidemment vous avez tous et toutes
vos chances pendant cette émission en
composant le 36 68 33 33
eh bien vous pourrez peut-être être
tirés au sort au standard et vous
pourrez donc ainsi vous élancer sur des
parcours et dieu sait s'ils sont
nombreux parce que y'a pas ses mots avec
hugo n'est ce pas le publier le thé les
puzzles la piste infernal enfin bon 36
68 33 33
et vous allez faire vous plaidez les
joueurs équipe avec un parrain de choix
tout de suite petit rituel on aime bien
les traditions dans les délires du go
pour vous aider à deviner de qui il
s'agit aujourd'hui quelle est la star
que nous accueillons je vous demande
tous vos applaudissements
pour antoine
quoi
toi
[Applaudissements]
puisque cette émission grâce à thouars
est placée sous le signe de l' aventure
une question s'impose tourner
aventuriers préféré abandonner préférées
je crois que c'est armstrong n'ont pas
le seul qui chante what a wonderful
world mais je suis le premier qui a
marché sur la lune parce que ça vraiment
c'était ça aurait été mon rêve je crois
que malheureusement je pouvais pas
marcher sur la lune un jour mais
j'aurais bien voulu y arrive plus et qui
sait peut-être j'espère qu'on va vite
inventé un dvd des vedettes spatial où
on puisse aller se balader librement
comme avec un bateau à bout en bout la
galette des poignets de l'espace
pourquoi pas au sa fraîcheur ce serait
le rêve ça et wahib au wat en aventurier
préféré bac la reine voyons ohlala
j'allais le dire ou quelle bêtise c'est
l'énigme du jour justement je ne peux
pas le dire maintenant rayons il a les
gaffes et ont effectivement vous avez
compris l énigme à résoudre pendant une
heure l'émission interactive en direct
c'est qu'elle est l'aventurier préféré
de notre you go c'est très facile c'est
facile et oui c'est facile on verra ça
en tout cas ce que je vous conseille
c'est à nouveau de vous précipiter sur
au téléphone pour composer le 36 68 33
afin d'avoir une chance de vous élancer
sur un parcours et vous aurez comme
parrain vous l'avez compris
antoine c'est moi tout au long de cette
émission et vous allez donc devoir
affronter la famille de la croix tu a
immédiatement débuté cette émission je
vois marie claude qui prend une
respiration profonde marie claude savard
guy marie claude à suspense est
insoutenable
allons
mariko c'est la première fois que vous
trouvez comme ça sur un plateau télé
première fois première fois mais vous
êtes j'espère une habituée des délires
du go quand même absolument vous savez
ce qui vous attend je sais ce qui
m'attend d'accord et bien par tirage au
sort
le parcours qui vous revient et celui du
train alors histoire de vous rafraîchir
un peu la mémoire marie-claude le bourg
donc faire fonctionner le petit à
gonesse sur lequel hugo à grande vitesse
va rouler sur des rails
il va falloir utiliser le 4 pour aller
sur la gauche le 6 pour aller sur la
droite
bien sûr le but du jeu c'est de
décrocher le plus possible de sacs d'or
très important pour les points et
d'éviter les voies de garage et les
locomotives qui à des vitesses
absolument vous vertigineuse risquerait
d'en placer notre goût vous avez compris
ce que je réclame 4500 points pour
décrocher d'office le premier indice ok
marie-claude c'est bien est ce qu elle
peut le faire
oui elle va le faire ça démarre bonne
chance tu es prêt voilà le rapide du
soir ni antoine 4500 points sont
nécessaires si jeune mais marie faut
donner sa tv pas stéphane son fils la
route et serait en vente offre magique
et tu aura intérêt à regarder les offres
magique parce que
aïe aïe aïe ça fait très mal on comprend
pourquoi on se repose tout reste dans la
semaine et on est lors dès lors qu'elle
gamelle deux minutes d'arrêt buffet
allait aller en voiture
le but du jeu n'étant pas d'écrabouiller
transformé en crèche
voilà la vérité
l'accord allait vite au risque est là
mais regardez bien la droite de l'écran
c'est tellement plus simple
le tracé du parcours en plan
anticiper en voyant arriver les le
prototype de croisière à les autobus
sûrs que vital n est à nouveau but sur
balles
faites-moi de grimper
vous savez qu'il est très importante à
chaque aventure de récolter le plus
possible de points occupe donc qui en
aura récolté le plus grand droit tous
trois ont promis de répondre à lisier
mort à londres
alamo
ban
sa mort
on a réussi
puis bon j'espère que la première
locomotive t'as pas fait trop mal tu
peux nous donner très officiellement le
score tout de suite allé le voici le
voilà
[Applaudissements]
4300 points s'est allégée en vidéo que
c'est magnifique ce serait absolument
extraordinaire si vous en aviez récolter
200 mieux parce que vous auriez pu tout
de suite avoir un indice sans prendre de
risques avec stéphane
mais à présent stéphane d'attenté le
repêchage stéphane écart qui bien les
yeux repère bien la forme de la serrure
du coffre tu t'entraînes antoine parce
que peut-être aura-t-il un repêché un
thé les joueurs tout à leur évite dis à
ta maman si c'est la clé numéro 1 au
numéro 2 et numéro 3 qui peut ouvrir ce
kof par rapport à leur forme la question
aura toujours des lycées dans la serrure
à l'appeler numéro en toile ne semblent
pas d'accord
antoine furedi l'acquéreur j'aurais dis
là
antoine tu penses que c'était la clé
numéro je pense était là oui monsieur
oui ce qui fait que on vient de rater
notre premier indice s ils sont précieux
pour l'énigme a tout de suite
antoine on va accueillir au standard et
bien le thé les joueurs qui sur un
parcours également avec hugo va essayé
d'affronter faire mieux donc que notre
famille la famille de la croix se tait
les joueurs ce candidat eh bien c'est la
personne qui au standard a répondu en
premier à la question que tu nous pose
immédiatement la question la première
question que je pose je mets mes
lunettes parce que c'est une question
très difficile très très difficile je
suis né où est ce que je suis née à
madagascar
est-ce que je suis né à marseille où est
ce que je suis né à paris et bien qu'ils
qui au sens large en temps une petite
voix allauch à l'eau à madagascar
madagascar
voilà quelqu'un qui est la culture bravo
eh bien non ce qui veut dire que le
soleil était présent déjà le jour de ta
nea oui oui je suis déjà nés dans une ni
deux voilà sous de très bons auspices
franchement elle appartient qui cette
petite voix mignonne à damien d'amiens
oui c'est ça tombe famille c'est quoi
d'année damien cougar chapelle d'où ces
deux régions près de roi des rois de la
scène bon à mon avis fait beaucoup moins
chaud romain bouquet à madagascar en
effet simon était pas bien vieux d'à
bien quel âge as-tu j'ai 11 ans tué à 11
ans ok cas fidèle des délires du gros
oui gros tu fais bien tu sais quel
parcours honteux réserves sur fait c'est
par tirage au sort on a pu établir tout
ça tu vas partir en balade avec hugo en
montagne bon juste tu te laisses
parcours n'est ce pas c'est très simple
ecoute-moi d'amiens il va falloir que tu
utilises leucate pour permettre à notre
l'ubo de sauter sur les plateformes
récupérer les sacs d'or important pour
les points et utilisera le sac pour
éviter les précipices d'accord ok ok ils
sont très déterminés prêts à gagner
je serai une bonne chance
allez mettons bonnet bon j'aime
l'aventuré la réplique à continue ainsi
jusqu'au bout dans la peau ça permettra
d'ailleurs
j'ai la pierre que ça allait bien n'être
pas le juste de le coup de sayada ces
prêts ont grimpé j'allais dire ça allait
permettre à antoine de ne pas trop se
casser la tête sur le jeu du coffre
magique tu sais qu'il faut faire que
marie-claude parce que nos deux églises
une montée les joueurs et la famille
s'affrontent et marie-claude elle a
obtenu quand même 4300 points sur le
premier parcours joly alors non restons
pas à cette bien il va falloir
absolument damien que tu fasses 6 e
store subi parce que je te rappelle qu'à
la fin de l'émission c'est l'équipe qui
a le plus de poids qui en prenait trois
dernières dictatures le 3 c'est l'équipe
qui a le plus de points qui en premier
pour la première réponse des ligues du
jour
le cuivre et le zinc qui tenta de faire
des signes incroyable ces prêts ont
grève et si on soit 150 points dont
vapor rester là maintenant c'est une
petite balade de santé jusqu'au bout ce
sentier est allé habitants paraissait ne
quitte pas beaucoup de villes attention
c'est notre dernière chance
il va falloir absolument qu'on prévoit
antoine un parcours brugot en pleine mer
par force et ris je vais vous aider
[ __ ] dessinée l'a1 interactif un jeune
ça très bien la rougeole est content qu
on bavarde elle s'était concentré faut
sauter comme cet objet arrive mais bien
sûr il fallait absolument aller soleil
est sur la plateforme
[Applaudissements]
pivot oui essaye de tester un petit peu
débarrasse toi tous et gravillons
retrouve ses esprits et d'entre nous le
score mais voilà alors
[Musique]
en ce début d'émission one sait ce qui
lui reste à faire alors c'est à moi de
reconnaître la clé c'est sa démission
alors la famille alors quand vous voulez
on essaye bien mais là je sens qu'il va
trouver là trois bagues le moment là
trois pas total à 3
ouais
ah j'ai gagné tout ça je vis avec
quelques amis tout ça
tout est dit ou presque il faut à
présent se reconcentrer pour partir pour
une seconde aventure et vous savez de
laquelle il s'agit il s'agit du buggy
je sais pas si je peux oui ce serait
être un petit peu curieux comme question
te parler de voiture est ce que explique
moi explique mme en l'ajout du poids
voilà oui mais parce que pour quelqu'un
qui est tellement épris de grands
espaces de voyages qui aiment entendre
le vent dans les voiles parler des
vrombissements de moteur sans abri un
savon bill ça vrombit alors là je te
garantis que ça vrombit presque comme
quand il s'agit d'un forçat 9 ou 10 et
bien écoute le jeu du buggy on a une
petite peluche qui installés sur ce mini
buggy et la famille ainsi que l'étaient
les joueurs vont pouvoir le faire
fonctionner simplement en tapant sur les
touches du clavier de téléphone et
renversé des cibles sur lesquelles sont
inscrits des scores qu'on va additionner
à la fin du parcours
bref ce que je demande et bien c'est que
on atteigne l'addition la plus élevée
possible et qui va s'élancer sur le
parcours du buggy qui il va bien falloir
y aller un moment ou un autre
allez stepan
stéphane tu me rappelle qu'on âge 8h30
huit ans et demi est ce que tu as des
voitures téléguidées chez toi oui bon
alors ça va être un jeu d'enfant pour
toi de faire ça un oui allez stéphane
dix mois que stéphane ça va très très
bien
oui bourse parfait pour le voir vous a
fait quoi quand tu souris haut c'est
super helvétique notent que j'aimerais
bien les voir c'est comment quand ils
seraient quelques notes aller montre moi
tes quenottes meute est mignon comme
tout comme ça stéphane sait comment ça
marche ah oui il y en a plus que toi à
tous les titres exclu qu'une dent mais
pas une vie si périlleuse que c'est déjà
miraculeux qui traite une dent et déjà
plus de cheveux sur la tête à mathieu et
stéphane et côtoient pour faire arrête
de rire jacky pour faire fonctionner ce
buggy c'est très important il ya quand
même un voyage en tunisie à la clé tu
sais que tu dois donc renverser le plus
possible de cible sur le plateau et tu
va utiliser le 4 pour le faire aller sur
la gauche le 6 pour le faire allez sur
la droite le 200 m et le 5 pour le faire
reculer
peut-être pour prendre de l'élan tu as
tout pigé oui bon tu vas y arriver
peut-on me dit papa être stéphane dit je
vais gagner voilà fait la marche est
comme ça allait tu t'occupes du chrono
je le doigt dessus et une minute 30
c'est parti
bonne chance stéphane allez vas-y
contours
super ça y est c'est bien c'est moins
technique l'a bien de cas déjanté la
route
autant voilà au c'est dur là
ah non pas le victor à l'espagne on
recule on tourne sous la droite ce sera
bien
produits voilà tu es mais bon là en quoi
les procès de cinq cents bon allez allez
à gauche bien à gauche c'est bon tu peux
être bon la baule et regarde la caméra
qui triche mais une fois cet automne
l'auront peut-être cela s'est produit en
a aucune avec les 5 et un petit peu sur
la gauche avance avance et en
n'utilisant que ça va être bon soyons
encore bondi d'un rabot stéphane natkin
s'il en reste 1 derrière toi là bas tu
peut reculer effectivement ces panneaux
se fasse demi-tour utilise le cadre
l'utilisent au cas comptez vous le 4
encore le 4 et encore le 4ème tour
bravo company mehdi les mamours efforts
un qui nous a fait un festival pour
quelqu'un qui nous a dit oui je vais
peut-être gagner je savais que j'allais
gagner je savais tu savais hugo annonce
nous bien officiellement montre nous les
chiffres regarde ton score stéphane ses
combattants voilà le score saint vil toi
super spéciale taratata maman et
provinces dans l'art du beau je sais je
sais tu va nous donner un autre à 10
minutes un deuxième indice et oui c'est
chez matra sinatra 6250 4324 su matra il
s'agit de harcy tut réunit des insurgés
auraient trouvé là mais c'est dur ça
c'est pas évident mais notre ne
t'inquiète pas on va donner des indices
de plus en plus explicites quoi au fil
de l'émission
mais pour l'instant il faut faire pas
trop évident quand même je suis sûr que
tu as trouvé déjà noms n'ont pas encore
je cherche toi toi tabac voire 1200
combien milles de saint vincent patron
de capa sont massés 24 bon maintenant je
cherche je cherche pendant la pâque oui
je me tais je suis sûr qu'il va trouver
bien évidemment d'entrer très peu de
temps
[Musique]
bonjour à tous radi de brevet pour cette
épice infernal place à l'action passe à
l'émotion place aux sensations c'est
stéphane qui va s'élancer sur cette
piste
redoutable c'est ça stéphane allez on
encourage ses fans remplace donc au
téléphone
en face du grand écran stéphane est ce
que tu peux me rappeler la règle du jeu
ses fans est ce que tu peux me rappeler
la règle du jeu il faut appuyer sur
quelques touches pour avancer pour
parler plus en plus vite l'enfant et ont
gagné 8
voilà donc t'as tout compris c'est pas
très compliqué avec leucate de temps en
temps pour prendre les raccourcis
d'accord on compte sur toi stéphane on
encourage encore une fois pour ses fans
à bord de la voiture de rallye sur le
circuit
what is voici ta voiture qui va prendre
place sur la ligne de départ reste bien
concentré sur les deux éléments du
tableau de bord des plus importants à
mon avis les petites flèches pour la
vitesse maximale à laquelle tu de
négocier les virages
et puis vint sur ton levier de vitesses
que tu manipules grâce à son téléphone à
l'attention non pas à deux secondes où
la patrouille catholique
normal stéphane je vais te dire un petit
peu comme pour tout à l'heure il faut
quand même rester calmes bien souffler
et puis passer peut-être la seconde
voire la troisième si vraiment tu sens
mais jouer la prudence pour terminer au
moins un tour d'accord ses fans
allez c'est reparti deuxième moitié il
te restera une date à disposition par la
suite
allez ce n'est pas la seconde la
troisième place bon voilà reste en
seconde on reste calme là qui peut
passer la troisième la seconde aussi
pour sony
c'est vrai que dire
s'enchaînent et vitesse vertigineuse au
cap leucate stéphane trop tard
perd un petit peu de temps
comprendre
délestage à il faut passer la première
quand même pour avancer le 2 le de l'o2
stéphane appui soit touchée brodeuses
encore une fois pour passer la seconde
la troisième compagnie chian troisième
ici 161 kilomètres heure
la 85e mon cher stéphane voilà qui est
un petit peu osé et ça te coûte une
pâture
on retrouve la troisième et dernière
voiture essaye d'assurer tu ferais
vraiment plaisir
ok stéphane aller 3è et dernière 53
secondes et la première mais qu'est ce
qui se passe on a très bien été envoyée
et ça n'avance plus bas 16 dans les bois
la boîte de vitesses étaient mal réglée
par les mécaniciens tout à l'heure 3e 4e
attention bon c'est vrai que c'est la
longue ligne droite mais tu auras un
virage en troisième ont pas de s'être
mis le droit d'auteur
le voici d'ailleurs voilà jouèrent moi
c'est bien je vais évidemment toujours
la troisième pour celui là
la seconde d'avancé il faut penser à
mettre en garde et
mais la troisième
[Applaudissements]
arrêté au pas moi de pouvoir est passée
la première
voilà la touche numéro 8 pour passer les
vitesses et on va boucler quand même ce
premier tour en une minute de 32
secondes et 66 centièmes attention
ils sont méchants c'est bien j'ai quitté
à négocier en seconde tu étais en
troisième c'était la dernière voiture
stéphane on tape on dit quand même très
très fort c'était pas mal bravo stéphane
un coup d'oeil sur le score de 1792 de
points
eh bien ce ne sera pas suffisant pour
récolter un avis supplémentaire est
immense et les uns d'histoire
aujourd'hui ego un petit peu avare on a
dit exceptionnellement j'ai envie de
donner deux indices dans le coup bah oui
parce que voilà qui généraux c'est
bientôt noël et puis quoi on s'amuse non
allez on vous jette pourtant aventuriers
rage même indice c'est kubilai khan et
le quatrième indice c'est venise
ils appellent ça un indice kubilai khan
bah oui c'est un indice oui tu connais
vrai qu'on a peut-être qualité
supplémentaire l'icann ça mérite de
s'accrocher parce que tout ça ça sert
bertrand a voyagé regard ou alors vous
participer à une épreuve des délires du
lot kenneth parker vous à fos 2xl
un drôle de robot interactif qui pensent
et qui parle il vous pose des questions
et y répond avec une vraie personnalité
vous avez réussi votre aventure bontempi
vos propos ce music lab qui comprend un
clavier électronique une cassette un
livre méthodes et trois livres et de
musique un véritable professeur vous
n'avez pas trouvé l'énigme matra vous
offre ce répondeur
interrogé à distance héridis et en plus
ce téléphone sans fil look 300 avec son
antenne flexible
bravo vous avez trouvé l'énigme vous
partez à 2 pour une semaine de rêve de
détente de soleil et de loisirs à
eldorador salammbô en tunisie avec des
taux et air france à l'autre j'apprends
petit bout qui en premier va pouvoir se
prononcer marie-claude la minute est
grave on surveille nouveau la liste des
indices oui allons-y à les survols ont
rapidement la liste des indices 1250
4324 sumatra we like we like cannes et
venise et venise
alors claude marie claude cheysson clair
que vous vous êtes fait une idée précise
et surtout bonne de l'aventurier préféré
de gros selon vous c'est l'histoire les
colons non ce n'est pas christophe
colomb à 6 heures de colle ont dit au
standard du jeu il faut pas qu'il y ait
là je suis chaud que tu sais qui au
standard a eu le meilleur score et va
pouvoir répondre 8
la dette c'est à dire c'est un être oui
quelle école
la planète le net tu as fait le mur ce
qu'on ressent la rtu vient de remporter
un voyage en tunisie pendant dix jours
au soleil avec la personne de son choix
de magnifiques je viens d au soleil avec
toi il rassemble bouchon part au travail
merci 42 80 euros voire à la semaine
prochaine on s'est bien amusé
[Musique]